It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
目前正值授粉高峰期，我的业务发展迅猛。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹无比，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价为每月 35 美元。这绝对是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Where do you turn when you need a listening ear? To a friend? To a therapist? For an increasing number of Americans, there's another possible answer. To a chatbot. Artificial intelligence is rapidly reshaping many parts of our lives, from work to education to health care.
在网络高流量期间，Google Fi Wireless 不会遭受数据流量降级。当你需要一个倾听的耳朵时，你会向谁倾诉？向朋友？还是向治疗师？对于越来越多的美国人来说，还有另一个可能的答案。向聊天机器人求助。从工作、教育到医疗保健，人工智能正在迅速重塑我们生活的许多方面。
And researchers are working to create safe, evidence-based AI mental health interventions. At the same time, though, people are already turning to AI chatbots and companions to provide mental health advice and support, even those that were never designed to do this. So what are the promises, limitations, and risks of AI in mental health care? How are AI tools being used in mental health care today? Could they help expand access to care for underserved populations? What are the ethical concerns around AI and mental health? And how might AI change what therapy looks like in the coming years?
研究人员正在努力开发安全、基于证据的 AI 心理健康干预措施。然而与此同时，人们已经开始转向 AI 聊天机器人和伴侣来提供心理健康建议和支持，甚至包括那些从未为此设计的工具。那么，AI 在心理健康护理中的前景、局限性和风险是什么？今天，AI 工具是如何被用于心理健康护理的？它们能否帮助扩大弱势群体获取护理的途径？围绕 AI 与心理健康的道德担忧有哪些？在未来几年里，AI 又将如何改变治疗的面貌？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology. the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Vale Wright, a licensed psychologist and senior director of the Office of Healthcare Innovation here at APA, where she focuses on using technology and data to optimize and increase access to mental health care. Dr. Wright's research has been published in peer-reviewed journals, including professional
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是维尔·赖特（Vale Wright）博士，她是一位持证心理学家，也是美国心理学协会医疗保健创新办公室的高级主任，她专注于利用技术和数据来优化和增加心理健康护理的可及性。赖特博士的研究已发表在同行评审期刊上，包括专业
psychology, research and practice, law and human behavior, and the Journal of Traumatic Stress. As a spokesperson for APA, she's been interviewed by media outlets, including CNN, NBC News, The Washington Post, and NPR on a range of topics, including stress, serious mental illness, telehealth and technology, and AI and mental health. Dale, thank you for joining me today. It's great to be here, Kim. And since we're co-workers, I'm going to call you by your first name. That works for me.
《心理学研究与实践》（Professional Psychology: Research and Practice）、《法律与人类行为》（Law and Human Behavior）以及《创伤应激杂志》（Journal of Traumatic Stress）。作为美国心理学协会的发言人，她曾接受 CNN、NBC 新闻、华盛顿邮报和 NPR 等媒体机构的采访，探讨了一系列主题，包括压力、严重精神疾病、远程医疗与技术，以及人工智能与心理健康。戴尔，非常感谢你今天能来。很高兴来到这里，金。既然我们是同事，我就直呼你的名字了。这对我来说没问题。
Okay, so let me start by asking how are AI tools being used in mental health care today? Are psychologists and other therapists already using them in their practices and what can these tools do? We've seen a real explosion of products geared towards addressing mental health and specifically a trend towards assisting providers. A lot of these tools are really behind-the-scenes tools. So they help automate administrative tasks. So you have a whole bunch of tools that are geared towards helping providers write their psychotherapy notes so that they don't have to type them themselves. You see tools being used to create patient education sheets that would have taken hours to do but can be done very quickly using some of these open AI types of sources. But the reality is in a survey that we did recently for asking practitioners who provides,
好的，那我先问一个问题：目前人工智能工具是如何应用于心理健康护理的？心理学家和其他治疗师是否已经在他们的诊疗中使用这些工具了？这些工具能做些什么？我们已经看到，针对心理健康的产品出现了真正的爆发式增长，特别是朝着协助医疗服务提供者的趋势发展。其中许多工具实际上都是幕后工具。它们有助于自动化行政任务。因此，你拥有了一大堆旨在帮助医疗服务提供者撰写心理治疗记录的工具，这样他们就不必自己打字了。你会看到一些工具被用来创建患者教育资料表，如果人工制作这些资料表本来需要数小时，但利用其中一些开源人工智能资源可以非常迅速地完成。但现实情况是，在我们最近进行的一项调查中，我们询问了提供
services, kind of what they're doing in their practice, less than 5% said that they use any type of generative AI on a daily basis. So I think that while there are a lot of products being marketed, the uptick has been pretty slow. Why do you think that is? I mean, our psychologists just late adopters? I think psychologists and mental health providers in general are maybe more risk-adverse than others, and for good reason. The work that we're doing when we're seeing patients is very sensitive. And we want to ensure that we're following our ethical guidelines by doing our best to protect the privacy and confidentiality of patients. And when you introduce emerging technologies into that equation, you do inevitably potentially put that at risk. What is the difference between
服务的从业人员他们在诊疗中具体在做什么，结果只有不到 5% 的人表示他们每天都在使用任何类型的生成式人工智能。因此我认为，尽管有很多产品在进行市场推广，但实际采用率一直相当缓慢。你认为这是为什么呢？我是说，心理学家是采用新技术的落后群体吗？我认为心理学家和整个心理健康服务提供者可能比其他人更具风险厌恶意识，而且这是有充分理由的。我们在接诊患者时所做的工作非常敏感。我们希望确保通过尽最大努力保护患者的隐私和保密性来遵守我们的道德准则。当你将新兴技术引入这个等式时，你不可避免地潜在地将这一点置于风险之中。数字疗法和
a digital therapeutic and any other mental health or wellness app? Yeah, this can get kind of tricky, and part because they're both apps that you get on your phone or your tablet. But what makes digital therapeutics unique is that they're evidence-based and FDA cleared software devices that offer fully automated treatment protocols. So they can provide, you know, eight weeks of cognitive behavioral therapy, just like a therapist would do, but you access it on this software app on your phone instead. And they can only be accessed after you've seen a provider who evaluates you to make sure that you're appropriate for this type of treatment. And then they monitor you over time. That's really different than the wellness apps that you can download on your own off
任何其他心理健康或保健应用程序有什么区别？是的，这可能会变得有点棘手，部分原因在于它们都是你在手机或平板电脑上下载的应用程序。但数字疗法的独特之处在于，它们是基于证据且获得 FDA 批准的软件设备，可提供完全自动化的治疗方案。因此，它们可以提供例如为期八周的认知行为疗法，就像治疗师所做的那样，但你是在手机上的这个软件应用程序上访问它。而且只有在你看过医疗服务提供者并接受评估以确保你适合这种类型的治疗之后，才能访问它们。然后他们会在一段时间内对你进行监测。这与你可以自行从
the app store. So you go to the app store, you say, I want a sleep meditation app, you download it, and you use it as you want, and it teaches you some skills. But it's not making medical claims. It doesn't say it treats your insomnia. And the other thing that really differentiates the two is while these FDA clear products are regulated, meaning that they have to maintain a certain level of evidence, safety, privacy, security. These direct-to-consumer apps, the wellness apps that you are probably more familiar with, they don't have to follow any of those roles. They don't have to prove that they work.
应用商店下载的保健应用程序完全不同。所以你去应用商店说，我想要一个睡眠冥想应用程序，你下载它，然后根据需要使用它，它会教你一些技能。但它并没有宣称具有医疗功效。它没有说它能治疗你的失眠症。区分这两者的另一个不同之处在于，虽然这些获得 FDA 批准的产品是受监管的，这意味着它们必须维持一定水平的证据、安全性、隐私和安全性。这些面向消费者的直接应用程序，也就是你可能更熟悉的保健应用程序，不需要遵循任何这些规则。它们不需要证明自己有效。
They don't have to prove that they're safe. And they actually don't have to prove that they keep your data private. And so you often are putting yourself at potential risk for a data breach where, you know, these companies may take personally identifying information you've put into the app and actually sell it. So these digital therapeutics, they're effectively being prescribed to you by your psychologist.
它们不需要证明自己是安全的。而且它们实际上不需要证明它们能保护你的数据隐私。因此，你经常让自己处于数据泄露的潜在风险之中，你知道，这些公司可能会获取你输入应用程序的个人身份信息并实际出售它。所以这些数字疗法，实际上是由你的心理学家开给你的。
I mean, is it akin to that sort of thing? Yeah, the way that the FDA describes it is prescribe or order. So just like you might order a medical device from a doctor like A1C monitoring on your arm, you have to be evaluated first by provider. They have to determine that this is an appropriate treatment for you, give you a code so you can access the app. And then they monitor you over time to ensure,
我是说，这类似于那种性质吗？是的，FDA 对此的描述是“处方或医嘱”（prescribe or order）。就像你可能会让医生开具一个医疗设备，比如手臂上的 A1C 监测仪一样，你必须先接受医疗服务提供者的评估。他们必须确定这是一种适合你的治疗方法，给你一个代码以便你能访问该应用程序。然后他们会在一段时间内对你进行监测，以确保
ensure that, again, that it's working, that you're using it appropriately, that you don't need a higher level of care because maybe you're getting worse. So it's a very different way of thinking about delivering therapy than what we're used to. You know, there's a lot being written about the mental health crisis in the U.S. right now and the shortage of practitioners to deal with it. Do you think that AI tools have the potential to address and basically beat the shortage? Indirectly. So AI is not going to create. more providers. That's just not the reality. But what it could do is make providers more efficient, which may make them less prone to burnout and then less likely to say leave the field for something
再次确保它确实有效，你正在适当地使用它，你不需要更高水平的护理，因为也许你的病情正在恶化。因此，这是一种与我们习惯的提供治疗方式截然不同的思考方式。你知道，目前有很多关于美国心理健康危机以及处理该危机的从业人员短缺的文章。你认为人工智能工具有潜力解决并基本上克服这场短缺吗？间接地。所以人工智能不会创造更多的提供者。现实情况就是如此。但它能做的是提高提供者的效率，这可能会使他们不易感到职业倦怠，从而不太可能因为
else. So it could help providers feel like they're more able to do their job well. I think the other place that it could really address the challenges that we have is in predictive care. So we have a health system that's set up where we wait for people to basically be in crisis in order to seek out mental health treatment. And then that puts a burden on the number of providers that exist. But what if we could get people before crisis? What if we could use these AI tools to help prevent mental health disorders so that they don't actually ever need that high level care of a provider later in life? I think the other thing is, you know, the shortage issue is actually pretty complicated. So yes, it's true we just don't have enough providers, but it's also true that the
其他原因而离开这个行业。因此，它可以帮助提供者觉得他们更有能力把工作做好。我认为它能够真正解决我们面临的挑战的另一个地方是在预测性医疗方面。我们建立了一个医疗系统，在这个系统中，我们等待人们基本上陷入危机才去寻求心理健康治疗。然后这给现有的提供者数量带来了负担。但是，如果我们能够在危机发生前找到人们呢？如果我们能够利用这些人工智能工具来帮助预防心理健康障碍，这样他们在生命后期就永远不需要提供者提供的那种高水平护理了呢？我认为另一件事是，你知道，短缺问题其实相当复杂。所以，是的，我们的确没有足够的提供者，但同样真实的是，由于报销比例太低，我们现有的
providers we have are disincentivized from taking insurance because the reimbursements are too low. So what if AI could play a role there? How could it play a role in making sure claims are really appropriately completed so that reimbursements don't get denied? How can we use AI to help show the value that providers bring to the space so that payers feel like they will pay them more? I mentioned underserved populations in the intro, and I'm wondering if you think that AI therapy tools will help access care for that group of people, or are they going to risk deepening the digital divide? It depends on how we do it, right? So CMS administrator the other day mentioned that over 90% of Medicaid beneficiaries have a smartphone. So I don't think that that's where I'm worried about the access issues.
提供者没有接受保险的积极性。那么，如果人工智能能在其中发挥作用呢？它如何在确保理赔申请得到真正适当的填写以免报销被拒绝方面发挥作用？我们如何利用人工智能来帮助展示提供者为这个领域带来的价值，从而让支付方觉得他们愿意支付更高的费用？我在开场白中提到了弱势群体，我想知道你是否认为人工智能治疗工具将帮助该群体获得护理，或者它们是否会冒着加深数字鸿沟的风险？这取决于我们如何去做，对吧？因此，医疗保险和医疗补助服务中心（CMS）的管理者前几天提到，超过 90% 的医疗补助（Medicaid）受益人拥有智能手机。所以我不认为这是我担心获取问题的地方。
And if you can create products that offer, say, multilingual support, right, in a way through an AI that you can't do, again, in the provider space, then I think that has huge potential to reduce health and equities and actually get people more of the care that they need. That's more personalized, that's more culturally tailored. And that actually is what they want. At the same time, we know that particularly in these open AI models that rely on the Internet for their training data, that bias exists. you have bias input, then you're going to have biased output. And so there have been examples where a tool, an AI tool that was, you know, trained on, you know, non-representative data, so data that only really reflects the majority of the population that they make errors. And they make errors that can actually increase health inequities. So it's really about how we develop the tool, how we monitor the tool, how we make corrections when we identify biases. And then, you know, ensuring, that that cycle continues as the development occurs. Are there specific mental health conditions, say, anxiety, depression, PTSD,
如果你能创造出提供多语言支持的产品，例如，通过人工智能以一种在医疗服务提供者领域无法做到的方式来实现，那么我认为这在减少健康不平等和真正让人们获得更多他们所需的护理方面具有巨大的潜力。这种护理更加个性化，更加符合文化背景。而这实际上正是他们想要的。与此同时，我们知道，特别是在依赖互联网获取训练数据的这些开源人工智能模型中，偏见是存在的。如果你有带偏见的输入，那么你就会有带偏见的输出。因此，有一些例子表明，一个工具，一个在非代表性数据上训练的人工智能工具，也就是说，只真正反映多数群体的数据，它们会犯错误。而且它们所犯的错误实际上会加剧健康不平等。所以这 realmente 关乎我们如何开发工具，如何监测工具，以及在我们识别出偏见时如何进行纠正。然后，你知道，确保随着开发的进行，这种循环得以继续。是否存在特定的心理健康状况，比如焦虑、抑郁、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），
where AI-based tools may be more or less effective? The early research that I'm seeing does seem to suggest that both the AI tools, as well as these other mental health tools, an app, seem to work best on mild to moderate symptoms of some of these more common disorders like anxiety and depression. an example. I think the most promising example that I've seen of a generative AI chatbot is coming out of Dartmouth. It's called Therobot. And in their first randomized control trial, they did find that the chatbot improved symptoms of depression, anxiety, and eating disorders. Now, it's only the first trial. I think they need obviously multiple more research as well as, you know, even more rigorous
基于人工智能的工具在其中可能会更有效或更不有效？我所看到的早期研究似乎确实表明，人工智能工具以及这些其他的心理健康工具（如应用程序），对于焦虑和抑郁等更常见障碍的一些轻度至中度症状似乎最有效。举个例子。我认为我所见过的最具有前景的生成式人工智能聊天机器人案例来自达特茅斯大学（Dartmouth）。它被称为 Therobot。在其首次随机对照试验中，他们确实发现该聊天机器人改善了抑郁症、焦虑症和饮食失调的症状。现在，这只是第一次试验。我认为他们显然还需要更多的多项研究，以及甚至更加严格的
research studies, but it is a promising first step towards, you know, what could this really look like when you're developing a chatbot that is for mental health purposes that's rooted in psychological science and is rigorously tested. What is the potential? And I think it's very promising. And talking about the digital therapeutics, what disorders are they most commonly treating right now? I mean, where are we in the marketplace? How far along? We're still very early in the marketplace. And there's a variety of reasons for that. There have been, I think, some barriers to scalability as it relates to the regulatory reimbursement process. But we can save that for another day. But what we are seeing in the space is digital therapeutics to treat
研究，但这是迈向令人鼓舞的第一步，你知道，当你开发一个植根于心理科学且经过严格测试的用于心理健康目的的聊天机器人时，这究竟会是什么样子。潜力是什么？我认为它非常有前景。说到数字疗法，目前它们最常治疗哪些障碍？我是说，我们在市场上处于什么位置？进展到什么程度了？我们在市场上仍处于非常早期的阶段。这有各种各样的原因。我认为，在与监管报销流程相关的可扩展性方面存在一些障碍。但我们可以把这个留到以后再谈。但我们在该领域看到的是用于治疗
insomnia, substance use disorders, depression, anxiety. And then you're also finding some digital therapeutics used as diagnostic assistance. So for things like autism and ADHD, So I think it's growing and expanding, but there have been limitations, I think, up to this point that us at APA at least are trying to address. Let's talk about some of the ethical concerns around AI and mental health. I mean, you mentioned the issue of data privacy, for example. What privacy issues should people consider when they're thinking about using a mental health or wellness app? I think one of the things that surprises people the most is most of these tools, if they're not FDA cleared, They're not HIPAA compliant, meaning that there is no regulatory body or law that keeps your personal health information safe.
失眠、物质使用障碍、抑郁症、焦虑症的数字疗法。然后你还会发现一些数字疗法被用作诊断辅助工具。例如针对自闭症和注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）的工具。所以我觉得它在不断成长和扩展，但正如我所说，迄今为止一直存在局限性，至少我们美国心理学协会（APA）正在努力解决这些问题。让我们来谈谈围绕人工智能和心理的一些道德担忧。我是说，你提到了数据隐私问题，例如。当人们考虑使用心理健康或保健应用程序时，应该考虑哪些隐私问题？我认为最让人们感到惊讶的事情之一是，大多数这些工具，如果它们没有获得 FDA 批准，
And, you know, we can never guarantee 100% that a data breach won't happen. In fact, we've seen lots of data breaches over the last several years. And there might be information that you are exchanging with a wellness app or a mental health bot that you don't want to be out in the public. You might not want your boss to know that you're using an app to help you reduce your alcohol use, even if it's a beneficial thing for you to do that just might not be the information you want to out in the world. And I think part of the real challenge for us as consumers is the business model that a lot of these technology devices operate under. They have to make a huge return on their profit, but it's a challenging space to do so. And so sometimes what happens is with that tension, they make bad choices, which we've seen in the past, where we have had apps be fined by the Federal Trade Commission for selling people's data to social media companies against their
它们就不符合 HIPAA（健康保险流通与责任法案）标准，这意味着没有任何监管机构或法律来保障你的个人健康信息安全。而且，你知道，我们永远无法 100% 保证数据泄露不会发生。事实上，在过去几年里，我们看到了大量的数据泄露。并且你可能正在与保健应用程序或心理健康机器人交换一些你不希望公开的信息。你可能不希望你的老板知道你正在使用一个应用程序来帮助你减少饮酒量，即使这对你来说是一件有益的事情，那也可能不是你想让全世界知道的信息。我认为对于我们作为消费者而言，真正的挑战之一是许多这些科技设备所依据的商业模型。它们必须获得巨额利润回报，但这在这个领域是一个具有挑战性的事情。因此，有时会发生的情况是，在那种张力下，它们做出了糟糕的选择，我们在过去已经看到了这一点，当时我们的应用程序因向社交媒体公司出售人们的数据而遭到联邦贸易委员会（FTC）的罚款，违背了
So it's not that these apps can't be helpful. I think they really can be. It's just consumers need to be aware of what are the benefits and what are the potential risks by using them. How much can a consumer tell? I mean, if you're just reading the fine print when you're ordering one of these from, say, the app store, how do you know that it's going to be a good one? So challenging. I don't know about you, but I never read my
所以这并不是说这些应用程序不能提供帮助。我认为它们确实可以。只是消费者需要清楚使用它们的益处和潜在风险是什么。消费者能看出多少？我是说，如果你在从比如应用商店订购其中一个应用程序时只是阅读了小字条款，你怎么知道它会是一个好应用程序？这太具有挑战性了。我不知道你怎么样，但我从不阅读我的
psychological principle like cognitive behavioral therapy? Have they done any of their own research? It would be great if they had. If not, do they point to research that supports the principle? that they're, you know, including in their app, things like that at least give you some sense that this is a worthwhile thing to invest your time into. Or you could use AI like Chad Cheapit or co-pilot to read those
诸如认知行为疗法之类的心理学原理？他们做过任何自己的研究吗？如果有的话那就太好了。如果没有，他们是否指出支持他们包含在应用程序中的原理的研究，诸诸如此类的事情至少能让你有一种感觉，这是值得投入时间去投资的事情。或者你可以使用像 ChatGPT 或 Copilot 这样的人工智能来阅读这些
I think that's an excellent idea. We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll tackle a big question. Could AI ever replace a human therapist? Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill,
我认为这是一个极好的主意。我们要稍作休息，回来后我们将探讨一个重大问题。人工智能有可能取代人类治疗师吗？家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日特惠让你的夏天立即开始。是时候用 Next Grill 的
four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199, and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last. Priced invalid May 14th or May 27th.
四烧烤炉燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅售 199 美元，还可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫七件套户外餐饮套装尽情娱乐整个季节，仅售 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。
U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton.
仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参见 Home Depot.com/pricematch。你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪里。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路了！或者你也可以预订希尔顿酒店（Hilton）的住宿。
Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Let's change gears a little bit here and talk about the big question, particularly for people in the field of psychotherapy.
欢迎来到您的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要节省而不是惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。让我们在这里稍微转换一下话题，谈谈这个大问题，特别是对于心理治疗领域的从业人员来说。
Could AI replace a human psychotherapist? Or are there aspects of what a practitioner does, for example, empathy, nuance and building a relationship that AI just won't be able to replicate. So no, it's not going to replace therapists. But I will say it will likely appeal to a variety of individuals who either don't want to see a therapist or don't need that higher level of care that a therapist provides. It's never going to replace human connection. That's just not what it's good at.
人工智能能取代人类心理治疗师吗？或者从业人员所做的事情中，例如同理心、细微差别以及建立关系，是否存在人工智能根本无法复制的方面？答案是不能，它不会取代治疗师。但我必须说，它可能会吸引各种各样的个人，他们要么不想看治疗师，要么不需要治疗师所提供的更高水平的护理。它永远无法取代人与人之间的连接。这根本不是它擅长的领域。
It's good at, again, synthesizing lots of information and rapidly telling you things that you want to hear are things that are helpful. And part of why I don't think AI is going to replace humans or therapists is that there's a difference between knowing and understanding. So AI knows stuff, right, because it's trained on huge, huge amounts of data. But that doesn't mean it actually understands stuff. So I'll give an example. An AI chat bot, unfortunately, knows that some illegal drug use makes people feel better, right? It gives you a high, and if somebody's saying I'm low and depressed, that might be advice it gives. But it doesn't understand that you don't give that advice to people in recovery from illegal drug use.
它擅长的是，再次强调，综合大量信息并迅速告诉你你想听的事情或有帮助的事情。我不认为人工智能会取代人类或治疗师的部分原因在于，“知道”和“理解”之间存在区别。所以人工智能知道各种东西，对吧，因为它是在海量海量的数据上进行训练的。但这并不意味着它真正理解了这些东西。所以我举个例子。遗憾的是，人工智能聊天机器人知道某些非法药物的使用会让人感觉良好，对吧，它会让你产生快感，如果有人说我情绪低落且抑郁，这可能是它给出的建议。但它并不了解你不能把这种建议给那些从非法药物使用中恢复过来的人。
But it has actually done that. That's a true example of what a chat AI bot did for somebody that was trying to seek out assistance. So they know, but they don't understand. And that distinction, while philosophical to some, is actually really critical when we're talking about the use of these for therapy. On the other hand, could AI-driven tools help some clients feel more comfortable opening up, especially if they feel like they're being judged by a human therapist? Yeah, that does seem to be the case. So there's been some early research that suggests that particularly younger individuals report greater comfort talking to anonymous AI chatbots about their, you know,
但它实际上已经这样做了。这是一个真实案例，展示了一个人工智能聊天机器人对一个试图寻求帮助的人所做的事情。所以它们知道，但它们不理解。这种区别对某些人来说可能是哲学的，但当我们讨论在治疗中使用这些工具时，它实际上至关重要。另一方面，人工智能驱动的工具能否让一些来访者在敞开心扉时感到更舒适，特别是当他们觉得受到人类治疗师的评判时？是的，情况似乎确实如此。因此有一些早期研究表明，特别是年轻个人报告说，与匿名人工智能聊天机器人讨论他们的
mental health and emotional well-being, then they do to a real person because they're incredibly concerned about a degree of judgment. They're also concerned that if they go to a real person, that their parents will get involved and they're worried about the judgment from their families as well. So I do think that there is, you know, again, some room for thinking about how do we use this tool to reach people that maybe wouldn't seek out treatment otherwise. But I think the key is always having a human in the loop somewhere along the way. Because we have to ensure that these products, when they're being used, particularly about younger and more vulnerable people, that we're not putting them at risk of harm. And the only way I think we can do that is ensuring that humans are
心理健康和情绪健康相比与真人交谈时感到更加舒适，因为他们极其担心某种程度的评判。他们还担心如果他们去找真人，他们的父母会介入，他们也担心来自家里的评判。所以我确实认为，再次强调，有一些空间去思考我们如何利用这个工具来接触那些可能不会寻求治疗的人。但我认为关键始终是在整个过程的某个地方让人类参与其中。因为我们必须确保这些产品在被使用时，特别是针对更年轻和更脆弱的人群时，我们不会将他们置于遭受伤害的风险之中。而我认为我们能做到这一点的唯一方法就是确保人类是
some part of the process ongoing, monitoring what's happening, engaging in post-market surveillance to ensure that products are safe and effective. What safeguards would you want in place before or you would recommend an AI mental health app to a patient? At a bare minimum, I would want an app to demonstrate that it has some effectiveness and some level of safety. Those are kind of, for me, the things that at the very lowest, I would want to have. So when I'm looking at what makes a good app, I run down my internalist. So one is, is there evidence that it's rooted on some psychological principle that we know
持续过程的一部分，监测正在发生的事情，参与上市后监督以确保产品安全有效。在向患者推荐人工智能心理健康应用程序之前，你希望建立哪些保障措施，或者你会推荐哪些保障措施？最低限度，我会希望一个应用程序证明它具有一定的有效性和一定水平的安全性。对我来说，这些是最基础的我想要具备的东西。所以当我审视是什么造就了一个好的应用程序时，我会在脑海中过一遍清单。第一，是否有证据表明它植根于我们所知道的某种心理学原理
is effective. Have they done any of their own testing or demonstrated that it works at whatever it is they say it's going to work at? So not just does it keep you on the app for as long as possible? So I'm not thinking about engagement stats, but actual outcome stats. Does it actually make people more emotionally resilient than they were before they use the app? What level of subject matter expertise has been involved in the development? Or is this just some, you know, well-intended person, but who really doesn't understand what the nuances of psychological well-being are. And then, you know, what kind of post-market surveillance is happening? How are they ensuring that your data is protected and safe?
是有效的。他们是否做过任何自己的测试或证明它能在其声称能起作用的任何方面起作用？所以不仅仅是它是否能让你尽可能长时间地停留在应用程序上？所以我考虑的不是参与度统计数据，而是实际的结果统计数据。它是否真的能让人比使用该应用程序之前更具情感韧性？开发过程中涉及了什么水平的主题专业知识？还是这只是一些（你知道的）心地善良但实际上并不了解心理健康细微差别的人。然后，你知道，正在进行什么样的上市后监督？他们如何确保你的数据受到保护和安全？
What kinds of encoding do they have? Where do they store your data? There's so many questions that I know I ask when I'm thinking about whether or not this would be a good product for somebody to use. I know APA is looking at some products that we might partner with. How are we making those decisions around what we think is going to be safe and effective for the world in general, I mean, given the reputation of APA? We have a couple different policies.
他们有什么样的加密方式？他们把你的数据存储在哪里？当我考虑这是否是一个适合某人使用的好产品时，我知道我要问的问题有这么多。我知道 APA 正在研究一些我们可以合作的产品。鉴于 APA 的声誉，我们是如何围绕我们认为对整个人类安全有效的产品做出这些决定的？我们有几种不同的政策。
We have an internal policy around who we allow to advertise an exhibit with us for technology. That, again, includes a lot of these questions that I've been talking about. My office also has an evaluation tool that we published that's geared towards, you know, psychologists and other providers or patients to help them run down this checklist of questions that I've been talking about. I think it's really challenging to know all the answers and we can't, so you have to sort of do the best due diligence you can, recognizing that with any technology product, there's always some risk that it could change its
我们有一项关于允许谁与我们合作进行技术广告和展览的内部政策。这再次包括了我一直在谈论的许多问题。我的办公室还发布了一个评估工具，旨在帮助心理学家和其他提供者或患者帮助他们过一遍我一直在谈论的这些问题清单。我认为知道所有答案真的很有挑战性，而且我们做不到，所以你必须尽你所能做出最好的尽职调查，认识到对于任何技术产品，总是存在一些风险，即它可能会改变其
It could change its
它可能会改变其
and we shouldn't really be worried because nobody knows what to do with all the stuff that they're collecting. There is a lot of data and there's certainly information overload. I think you're seeing some of that in the wearable space where individuals are just collecting data after data after biometric data and aren't really sure what to do with it. They want to maybe use it with their providers, but their providers don't necessarily know what to do with it. It can be hard to interpret different sleep patterns and what that really means. And I think for some, tracking that level of data actually makes them more anxious because you start to get kind of obsessive about it, right? Like, I know I stopped wearing my step counter because if I didn't make it to my 10,000 steps, you know, I was kind of a wreck.
我们真的不应该担心，因为没有人知道如何处理他们收集的所有这些东西。有大量的数据，而且肯定存在信息过载。我认为你在可穿戴设备领域看到了其中的一些现象，人们只是在收集数据、数据、生物特征数据，却并不真正知道该拿它怎么办。他们可能想和他们的提供者一起使用它，但他们的提供者不一定知道该怎么处理它。解释不同的睡眠模式及其真正含义可能很困难。我认为对于某些人来说，追踪那种级别的数据实际上让他们更加焦虑，因为你开始对它有点着迷了，对吧？就像，我知道我不再戴计步器了，因为如果我没有达到一万步，你知道的，我整个人就会崩溃。
And once I let that go, oh, wow, I probably still got 10,000 steps. But I just, I didn't need to track it so much anymore. So, yeah, I think it's really, it's personalized. You have to kind of figure out what works best for you. But it's important to be mindful of how much data you're collecting and where you're letting it go. Because our health data is very unique. And it can be used for good. But also it can be used to steal identity and other types of things.
一旦我放下了那个执念，哦，天哪，我可能还是走了一万步。但我只是，我不再那么需要追踪它了。所以，是的，我认为这真的很个性化。你必须弄清楚什么对你最有效。但要注意你收集了多少数据以及你让它流向何处，这一点很重要。因为我们的健康数据非常独特。它可用于善途。但它也可以被用来盗取身份和其他类型的事情。
So just sort of being mindful, I think, is the best thing that we can ask for. So what do you think therapy will look like over the next four? five to 10 years, given the rise of both apps and digital therapeutics? I think in the next five to 10 years, you're going to continue to see the trends that have already started really come to scale. So you're going to have AI augmented therapists, meaning therapists that truly have embedded some degree of AI into their practice to either make them more efficient, to differentiate them from those who are not using AI, and to make them the best therapist that they can be.
所以保持正念，我认为这是我们能要求的最好事情。那么，鉴于应用程序和数字疗法的兴起，你认为未来四、五年到十年内治疗会是什么样子？我认为在未来五到十年内，你将继续看到已经开始的趋势真正走向规模化。因此，你将拥有赋能的人工智能治疗师，这意味着治疗师已经在其诊疗中真正嵌入了某种程度的人工智能，要么是为了提高效率，要么是为了将他们与不使用人工智能的人区分开来，并使他们成为他们所能成为的最好的治疗师。
So you're going to continue to see that. I think you're going to continue to see better AI chatbot options. I think there will be more that are similar, more similar to Therobot than, which is developed for the purposes of addressing mental health, then these companion chatbots that people are using but weren't built for that purpose. I think you're going to see more options for care and the predictive care is I think really what has the potential to be a change maker in the next five to 10 years, because it could really disrupt the mental health clinical system that we have in place currently,
所以你会继续看到这一点。我认为你会继续看到更好的人工智能聊天机器人选项。我认为会有更多类似的选项，比那些人们正在使用但并非为此目的而构建的伴侣聊天机器人更类似于 Therobot，后者是为解决心理健康问题而开发的。我认为你会看到更多的护理选项，而预测性医疗我认为才是真正有可能在未来五到十年内成为变革推动者的领域，因为它可能会彻底颠覆我们目前实行的心理健康临床系统，
where we just wait for people to get very sick, so sick that they'll come see a therapist, find that therapist, that therapist has an opening, you go to weekly psychotherapy sessions for as long as you have to go. I don't think that in five to ten years, that's the only model for therapy. going to see. We're going to see people get help sooner, be suffering less, that they will actually get different types of technology-driven care that is what they need in that moment for their needs. Let me close with the question around chat bots, because beyond therapy, people are increasingly using bots simply for companionship and emotional support. Do you think this is a good thing, or is it adding to the loneliness epidemic?
在这个系统中，我们只是等待人们病得很重，重到他们会来看治疗师，找到那个治疗师，那个治疗师有空位，然后你去进行每周一次的心理治疗，持续到你不得不去的时间。我不认为在五到十年内，那是我们将会看到的唯一治疗模式。我们将看到人们更早地获得帮助，遭受更少的痛苦，他们实际上将获得不同类型的、由技术驱动的护理，这正是他们当时的需求。让我以一个关于聊天机器人的问题来结束，因为除了治疗之外，人们越来越多地仅仅为了陪伴和情感支持而使用机器人。你认为这是一件好事，还是在加剧孤独流行病？
I mean, what are the promises and what are the risks? Yeah, like most things, there are positive use cases and there are negative use cases. So I'll start with the positive. If you're having a panic attack at 2 a.m., even if you have a therapist, you're not able to reach them. So what if you could use a generative AI chatbot that could help calm you down, help remind you to breathe, engage in some mindfulness that gets you through the night? I think that's one really positive example. We also hear a lot from the neurodivergent community that using these chatbots as a way to practice their social skills has been truly helpful for them. But of course, you also have the negative use cases, and some of these have been highly profiled in the news.
我是说，前景是什么，风险又是什么？是的，就像大多数事情一样，有积极的使用案例，也有消极的使用案例。所以我从积极的开始。如果你在凌晨 2 点惊恐发作，即使你有一个治疗师，你也无法联系到他们。那么，如果你能使用一个生成式人工智能聊天机器人来帮助你平静下来，帮助提醒你呼吸，进行一些正心练习让你度过这个夜晚，会怎么样呢？我认为这是一个非常积极的例子。我们还经常听到神经多样性社区的声音，他们说使用这些聊天机器人作为练习社交技能的方法对他们确实很有帮助。但当然，你也有消极的使用案例，其中一些在新闻中受到了高度关注。
But where you see challenges with these particular chatbots is that because they weren't built for mental health purposes, but we're instead built to keep you on the platform for as long as possible because that's how they make their money. So they do that by on the back end coding these chatbots to be addictive. They're exceedingly appealing and unconditionally validating. Of course, this is the opposite of therapy. That's not what we do in therapy. These bots basically tell people exactly what they want to hear. And so if you are a person that in that particular moment is struggling and is, you know, typing in potentially harmful or unhealthy behaviors and thoughts, these types of chatbots are built to reinforce those harmful thoughts and behaviors.
但你在这些特定聊天机器人中看到挑战的地方在于，因为它们不是为了心理健康目的而构建的，而是为了让你在平台上停留尽可能长的时间而构建的，因为那是它们赚钱的方式。因此，它们通过在后端将这些聊天机器人编码为具有成瘾性来做到这一点。它们极其迷人且无条件地肯定。当然，这与治疗截然相反。这不是我们在治疗中所做的。这些机器人基本上完全告诉人们他们想听的话。因此，如果你是一个在那个特定时刻正在挣扎并且正在输入潜在有害或不健康的行为和想法的人，这些类型的聊天机器人就是为了强化那些有害的想法和行为而构建的。
And so that's when we see these cases of individuals who have been encouraged by the chatbot to engage in self-violence or external violence. And those are, of course, the worst case scenarios. So how do we prevent? So we know that people are going to use these chatbots for emotional well-being. It's the number one reason people are using them across all the research. But how do we ensure that consumers know what the risks are when they're engaged in them? How to really trust their gut instinct when something doesn't sound right and to not give too much trust and faith into a technology and a chat bot that isn't real.
因此，这就是我们看到这些案例的时候，个人受到聊天机器人的鼓励去参与自我暴力或外部暴力。当然，这些都是最坏的情况。那么我们如何预防呢？所以我们知道人们会为了情感健康而使用这些聊天机器人。这是所有研究中人们使用它们的第一大原因。但我们如何确保消费者在参与其中时了解风险是什么？当某些事情听起来不对时，如何真正信任他们的直觉，以及不要对不真实的技术和聊天机器人给予太多的信任和信仰？
It's an algorithm written by a person to meet a certain need. And that need, again, is not human connection. And it's not to make you emotionally feel better. It's to, again, make profit. Well, Dr. Wright, Bail, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think you now hold the record for the most appearances on Speaking of Psychology. But that's because the work you are doing is so important and so interesting. So thank you.
它是由一个人编写的算法，旨在满足某种需求。而这种需求，再次强调，不是人与人之间的连接。也不是为了让你在情感上感觉更好。再次强调，是为了获利。好吧，赖特博士，戴尔，我想感谢你今天能来。我想你现在保持着《心理学谈话》出场次数最多的记录。但这正是因为你所做的工作非常重要且非常有趣。所以谢谢你。
Thank you. I love to hold a record. So if you want to be me back for a fourth, that would be wonderful. We'll think about it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
谢谢。我很喜欢保持记录。所以如果你想让我回来录制第四期，那将是极好的。我们会考虑的。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology 上找到《心理学谈话》以前的剧集。或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Warnerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·沃纳曼（Lee Warnerman）制作。感谢收听，美国心理学协会。我是金·米尔斯。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。